tras casi 310 en Turquía estos Soldados
del regimiento asov vuelven a su el
ucraniano estos cinco hombres eran
antiguos comandantes de guarnición en
Mario Paul y fueron llevados a casa tras
una reunión en Estambul entre bolo y
mirzalensky y recepta y perdón fueron
liberados de su cautiverio y enviados a
Turquía hace casi un año en un
intercambio de prisioneros entre Moscú y
kiev
hemos traído de vuelta a casa a Ucrania
a cinco de nuestros héroes Héroes de
Ucrania comandantes de la defensa de
Mario Paul y asoftal
sobrevivieron al cautiverio ruso han
pasado más de 300 días en Turquía es
hora de que estén en casa
el kremlin afirma que no fue consultado
sobre la liberación de los prisioneros y
condena el acto como una violación del
acuerdo con Ucrania que según Rusia
estipulaba que estos hombres
permanecerían en Turquía Hasta El Fin
Del conflicto según Moscú los aliados de
La otan presionaron ankara para que
intercambiará prisioneros antes de la
Cumbre de la próxima semana los
preparativos para la Cumbre de la otan
están en marcha y por supuesto hay mucha
presión sobre Turquía celebrados como
héroes en Ucrania pero despreciados en
Rusia por sus vínculos con los
ultranacionalistas ucranianos el
regimiento a soft libró una asedio de 3
meses contra las fuerzas rusas en la
ciudad portuaria meridional de Mario
Paul se escondió en plantas siderúrgicas
de asofstal antes de Rendirse finalmente
en mayo de 2022 los comandantes
liberados dicen que planean volver a la
lucha
a partir de hoy continuaremos la lucha
junto con ustedes no cabe duda de que
participaremos en la batalla
el presidente
ha prometido devolver a Ucrania todos
los demás prisioneros retenidos por